triple a nevada is expecting most of us
to stay home
for the holiday christmas travel will be
down because of the coronavirus in fact
the centers for disease control wants us
to stay home to slow the spread
but not everybody's doing that hector
mejia is live on the las vegas strip
with what some holiday travelers are
saying just before christmas eve hector
well first i talked with aaa
representatives this morning and they're
also warning against non-essential
travel and here at the welcome to las
vegas sign
people are still flocking this landmark
to get their pictures taken
you know most are getting around by car
aaa says
road trips are estimated to make up 96
percent of holiday travel this year
and according to aaa at least three
quarters of travelers are expected to
stay home this holiday season
that means 34 million fewer people
compared to 2019
and despite that drop though as many as
84.5
million americans are getting out anyway
between now and january third
the cdc is urging people to just stay
home
we asked visitors how they feel about
that warning and what brought them out
here
at a time when many are choosing to stay
in for the holidays
this was kind of iffy as well but
just us together what i recommend is
maybe a small road trip you know maybe
some of the parks you could see
or some of the landmarks you know we
thought maybe the hoover dam
but i think we landed here we are here
just for visiting state parks
to avoid all the kovitz scenario
2020 also ends the 11th year
of consecutive holiday travel growth it
was just last year when triple a
expected more people than ever on record
to rush home for the year and
celebrations and in terms of next year
2021 we are told that the covid vaccine
is bringing some promise some hope for
the industry
reporting from the las vegas strip
hector mejia 8 news now